we want to show that you can take a
depressed economic region and get that
region back up to where it needs to be
not in a twenty year program but in like
a two year program and just blow
people's minds walsim Berg has been
basically an old coal mining community
it was a very populated coal mining busy
town until the interstate kind of
bypassed us and ever since then and the
coal mines have shut down it's slowly
turned into a retirement community we're
right about three thousand people right
now that's James Acker the mayor of
Wallenberg a rural town located two
hours south of Denver near Colorado's
Spanish peaks landmark while Sandburg
has seen hard economic times since its
coal mine shut down in the 1960s the
town hoped the construction of a county
correctional facility in the early 2000s
would alleviate some of its financial
problems but the prison shut down in
2010 and within hopes of an economic
recovery probably the main industry
right now is welfare yeah I hate to say
that but we do have a lot of smart kids
that have came out of this town
and that's the biggest problem is
there's nothing here to keep them
nothing as Wallenberg struggled with
financial hardship northen Denver a
contractor named Bryant Ronnie was also
noticing a trend with customers looking
to build cannabis grows a lot of our
clients were immediately priced out of
the buildings or the indoor operations
that we built for them because they were
telling us to essentially take a few
hundred thousand dollars and block out a
perfectly good environment and then take
another few hundred thousand dollars and
recreate it and then they wanted to
spend fifty to a hundred thousand
dollars a month to maintain that
environment it didn't take long for us
to realize that the only reason that
people were really growing indoors was
just prohibition you don't grow alfalfa
indoors you don't grow corn or oranges
indoors the idea that we're going to
grow one of the highest producing dollar
crops
newest commodity found in America that
could quite possibly fix road and bridge
and infrastructure in its totality we're
gonna grow that indoors at a huge
expense and make brown plants instead of
green ones it didn't make a lot of sense
so Brian who owns the company Marchon
Holdings created a solution and drew up
plans to build an all inclusive
Marijuana greenhouse campus to lease to
cannabis growers he and his team took
hundreds of factors into consideration
for optimal growth and found 332 acres
in Wallenberg that would be an ideal
location to build the site at full
capacity is 92 Laight deprivation
greenhouses with approximately 15,000
square feet of greenhouse and 3,000
square feet of working and hen house in
those 15,000 square feet you've got
about nine thousand square feet of
actual flower space by doing it this way
they reduced their energy costs ninety
percent they move their operating
structure from anywhere around a hundred
to two hundred dollars per square foot
pro rata down to about forty dollars per
square foot complete pro rata these are
insane jumps when you're talking about
expanding or growing a business not only
will the facility help growers realize
profits but it has other potential
benefits the carbon footprint created by
the indoor production of cannabis is
significant and in our opinion has to be
worked on as quickly as possible so this
reduces those emissions by up to ninety
percent and that is something that's
near and dear to us the second goal is
to really prove that there is a
wholesale commodities market for
cannabis right now you've got a lack of
supply chain or at least a good supply
chain to market and you've got a very
inconsistent product when you get
everybody into one place under the same
standards and protocols we think that
you can fix the supply chain
additionally we think that you can fix
the consistency of product wallenberg
has embraced the project which started
construction in early November and
seized the greenhouse campus is a way to
revitalize the town's economy where
other cities like Denver have acted to
place strict regulations on marijuana
grows Wallenberg has made the decision
to
get out of the way for luck we have a
good forward-thinking Council in that we
see that there is a need and it's gonna
happen it's gonna happen like why can't
it happen to us they're gonna build up
the greenhouses they're gonna do that no
lease amount so that way the city don't
have that repetition of okay this green
house now we got to get clearance and we
got to do this and that where Martha is
gonna be the one that says okay I've got
these green houses for rent and he kind
of keeps the city out of it let them
handle their business
we'll handle our business what this city
has decided to do is to really uh
administrate it and take all of the
revenue and fix the infrastructure that
they're lacking and actually rebuild the
city so the administration here is
relatively simple the growers and the
cultivators will find that they've got
an over-the-counter licensing process
with the small hold
they've got reduced fees they've got one
gentleman in the Zoning Department one
gentleman in the building department one
city clerk one city administrator there
is not a two-week or 60-day lag through
Denver permitting which we suffer
constantly down here with them
streamlining everything it takes the
entire red tape out of the process for
the tenants wallenberg will also not tax
growers yield instead they plan on
making revenue by selling water the town
owns to the greenhouse facility by
removing red tape and partnering with
the cannabis industry the city hopes to
attract a thousand jobs to the area and
add much-needed revenue we want to also
prove estates model for cannabis we want
to show that you can take a depressed
economic region and through the use of
excise tax get that region back up to
where it needs to be not in a twenty
year program but in like a two-year
program and just blow people's minds
it's it's not just marijuana it's it's
an industry and that's what I'm looking
at is I think that's what's going to
help save Walter
you